this morning the Iranian government is
dismissing an angry warning from
President Trump to Iran's president
Hassan Ronnie told mr. Trump yesterday
not to push Iran too far sang war with
Iran is the mother of all wars president
Trump fired back with an overnight tweet
in all caps
never ever threaten the United States
again or you will suffer consequences
the likes of which few throughout
history have ever suffered before major
Garrett is at the White House major good
morning good morning the Iranian
president rouhani called president
Trump's tweet a quote passive reaction
all this rhetoric is kind of a prelude
about two weeks from now the United
States is scheduled to reimpose economic
sanctions on Iran those sanctions had
been lifted as part of the Iran nuclear
deal but remember President Trump took
the United States out of that in May
adding to all this Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo said even after those
sanctions are imposed bigger ones could
well follow everyone can agree that the
regime in Iran has been a nightmare
theory nyan people in a scathing speech
in California Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo accused Tehran's leadership of
spreading violence across the Middle
East and participating in widespread
corruption the level of corruption
wealth among Iranian leaders shows that
Iran is run by something that resembles
the Mafia more than a government
speaking to a largely Iranian American
audience Pompeo dismissed Iranian
president Hassan rouhani and his foreign
minister who negotiated the Iran nuclear
deal with the US and five other
countries while Duma she was in equities
earlier Sunday rouhani threatened mr.
Trump saying don't play with Alliance
Chael this would only lead to regret and
added that peace with Iran is the mother
of all peace and war with Iran is the
mother of all wars President Trump fired
back we are no longer a country that
will stand for your demented words of
violence and death be cautious the
United States will withdraw from the
Iran nuclear deal in May president Trump
withdrew from the 2015 nuclear agreement
designed to stop Iran from developing
nuclear weapons we are asking every
nation every nation who is sick and
tired of the Islamic Republic's
destructive behavior to join our
pressure campaign Pompey owes blistering
comments came before the Trump
administration prepares to reinstate
severe sanctions on Iran our focus is to
work with countries importing Iranian
crude oil to get imports as close to
zero as possible by November 4th zero
Ronni also suggested Iran may block
exports through the Gulf if sanctions
block its oil exports edits and he said
on may start restart its nuclear program
Gail he also called Secretary of State
Pompeii owes remarks funny and
ridiculous all right nobody's laughing
thank you very much major